hello everyone let me welcome you to
this new video learning where we're
gonna learn about lamda and I'm Samuel
from simply lung and I'm very glad that
you're watching this AWS lamda tutorial
now one day at office in a growing
company there was this question going on
between two IT personnel it was about
the new role that his colleague Jessica
has taken Benjamin the guy standing here
wants to know about it and Jessica's job
is new different and dynamic and
interesting to she scale and manage
servers and operating systems and apply
security patches onto them and monitor
all of these at the same time to ensure
the best quality for application is
given to the users and Benjamin was
awestruck with the amount of work
Jessica is doing and with the time it
would take to complete all of them but
Jessica being a very dynamic person very
suitable for the job said it was easy
for her to handle all of it and even
more but that easiness on the job did
not last longer as the environ grew more
and more it being a startup company
Jessica was getting drained and was not
really happy about all her job as she
used to be
Jessica's manual way of scaling and
environment did not last long
and she was also finding out that she
missed to scale down some of the
resources and it's costing her a lot she
needs to pay for the service that she
was not at all using she sort of filled
that she was at the end of the road and
there was no way out from this manual
tasks
she was very desperate and that's when
Benjamin suggested something and that
brought back the peace and joy
Jessica initially had Benjamin suggested
about a service called lambda that can
ease the work that Jessica is doing at
the moment and lambda as happy as it
looks like it's a solution that solves
the manual repeated work and lot more
and lambda introduced itself as the
problem solver and started to explain
the following things the very same thing
that we're gonna learn about in this
series so in this section we're gonna
learn about the features of AWS lambda
and we're gonna talk about what lambda
is and then we're gonna talk about
where lambda is being used in the IT or
in the cloud environment as we speak and
then we're gonna talk about how lambda
works and some use cases of lambda and
we're gonna be particularly discussing
about the use case about automatically
backing up the data that's put in the
cloud storage let's talk about lambda in
detail lambda automatically runs our
code without requiring us to provision
or manage servers just write the code
and upload it to lambda and lambda will
take care of it that means that we don't
require any server to run or to manage
and all you need to do is write the code
and upload it to lambda and lambda will
take care of it
which also means that we can stop
worrying about provisioning and managing
servers
the only thing lambda expects from you
is a code that's working a double is
lambda also automatically scales our
application by a running code in
response to each trigger our code runs
in parallel and processes each triggers
individually scaling precisely with the
size of the workload scaling here is
done automatically based on the size of
the workload lambda can scale the
application running the code in response
to each and every trigger that it
receives billing in lambda is meter on
the seconds we only pay for the amount
of time that our code is running which
means that we not charge for any of the
service the only payment required is for
the amount of time the code is computed
with a double use lambda we are charged
for every hundred milliseconds we are
actually charged for 100 milliseconds
our code executes and the number of
times our code is triggered and we don't
pay anything when the code is not
running let's talk about what is a
double use lambda now lambda is one of
the servers that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that AWS provides along with
ec2 EBS elastic load balancer lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
AWS and lambda allows us to execute code
or any type of application with AWS
lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or back-end services
all we need
to do is supply our code in one of the
languages that AWS lamda supports as we
speak the languages that are supported
by AWS lamda are node.js Java C sharp go
and Python and lambda can be used to run
call in response to certain events from
other services and based on the event it
can run functions and those functions
can be of no js' Java C sharp etc now
let's talk about where is lambda used
there are a huge number of use cases for
lambda and there are many ways a double
is lambda is used specifically in the
business world let's talk about some of
them one news case is a double use
lambda is used to process images when it
is uploaded in an s3 bucket let's say
the object gets uploaded in a nest a
bucket in a format that we don't expect
it to be which means the file needs to
be formatted so it gets uploaded in a
raw format and a double use lambda is
triggered anytime a new object is added
to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that would be reading the data it
could be an PC could be an Apple machine
it could be an Android phone it could be
an apple phone could be a tablet whatnot
so based on the devices different
formats lambda can get triggered and
convert the video or kind of the picture
into the different format that it
requires another use case for lambda is
to analyze the social media data let's
say let's say we collecting the hashtag
trending data and the data is received
and it's added into the Kinney's stream
to feed into the Amazon environment and
lambda action get triggered and it
receives the data and then the data is
stored into the database which can be
used by businesses for later analysis
and some of the companies that have
gotten tremendous benefit using lambda
or Thomson Reuters bench links
Nordstrom coca-cola robot are some of
the companies to name at the moment that
have received tremendous amount of
benefit by using lambda let's look at
how lambda works
in other words let's look at how the
complicated function behind-the-scenes
work in a simple and in a seamless way
so here our clients send data online
send data to lamda and clients could be
anyone
who's sending requests to AWS lamda it
could be an application or other Amazon
Web Services that sending data to the
lambda and lambda receives the request
and depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less requests it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the cord the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
standalone executable package off a
piece of software that includes
everything needs to run it like the
codes the runtimes the system tools the
system libraries and any of the settings
needed and it is at the moment available
both on Linux and Windows based
application and container rise to
software will always run the same
regardless of the environment it's
running on and containers isolate
software from its surrounding for
example there could be difference
between a development and staging
environment so that sort of isolated and
this helps in reducing the conflict
between the teams running a different
software on the same infrastructure
alright now that we know containers
needed to understand lambda so if there
are few requests it sends to a single
container but as in when the request
grows it actually creates multiple
containers shares the multiple requests
to the different containers there and
depending on the volume depending on the
size depending on the number of sessions
the more number of containers are
provisioned
so to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduced as well and that helps in saving
cost we're not running any resources and
paying for it when we
using them and in fact we're not at all
paying for the resources
we're only charge for the amount of time
a function is running inside these
containers now consider a situation
where you have to set up a temporary
storage and as a system to back up the
data as soon as the data is uploaded
which is a near real-time backup now a
near real-time manual backups are nearly
impossible and they're not that
efficient to and near real-time manual
backups that's what the business demands
but that's not near real-time backup
that to a manual one that's not at all
efficient even if we come up with a
solution of manually backing out close
to near real-time and that's not gonna
be efficient looking at the amount of
data that will be put in and looking at
the random times the data will be put
into the source bucket and there's no
way we can do a manual backup and they
keep it as real as possible but if
that's still your requirement we can use
AWS lambda and set things up so AWS
lambda manually handles the backup in
other words for an impossible or a
difficult situation like that
AWS lambda comes for the rescue and this
is what we do create a - s3 bucket 1
will be the source bucket where the data
will be uploaded and the other one is
and destination bucket where the data
will be backed up from the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an IM
rule and then for the automatic copy
it's gonna require and lambda function
to copy the files from the source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the lambda function the lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the bucket
and this data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's gonna automatically replicate or
that's gonna automatically copy the data
from the source packet to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
bucket well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in s
that's a feature that comes along with
s3 what if you want to replicate between
two different buckets in two different
accounts in those cases we can use
lambda to replicate the data and between
the buckets so you put one data or you
put data in the source bucket and that
data gets replicated to the destination
bucket and let's see how that's done the
procedure here will be to have two
buckets to begin with and then create an
IM role that lets you access to pull
data from the source bucket and put data
on the destination bucket and then
create lambda files or lambda event or
triggers to actually look for event in
the source bucket and anytime a new data
gets added lambda gets triggered copies
the data from the source bucket and
moves the data to the destination bucket
and it uses the IAM role and policy for
the needed permissions and in just a
couple of clicks we have set up a
temporary backup system that can run
seamlessly without any manual
intervention and that can be as near
real-time as possible all right that's
the concept and let's see how it is done
real time through this lab so to begin
with we need the two buckets so I have
here a source bucket and a destination
bucket and the source bucket as of now
do not have any data in it so as the
destination bucket all right so that's
one down the second would be to create
an IM role alright so let me create an
IM role and the role is gonna have this
policy in it a policy that's allowing
get object on the source bucket and a
policy that's a loving put object on the
destination bucket and here I'm gonna
use or I'm gonna paste my source and
destination buckets AR n alright Carew
services guru s3
source bucket
all right click on the source bucket
the bucket TRN
so that would be the source bucket AR n
right on on the destination bucket copy
the destination bucket AR n and this is
gonna be my destination bucket erm so
with this I'm gonna create a policy
alright good I am
and create a policy
now I I have already
get a policy
with the same information right
destination bucket hey RN and a policy
is available with the name s3 bucket
copy lambda attach the policy to the
roll
right guru roles create a role lambda is
the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it a name and then create a
role now I have a role created as well
all right copy lambda and that's having
the policy that we have created some
time back now create a lambda function
right so go to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right
choose the role that we want to use all
right that's the role that we want to
use copy one to create a function
all right
and in here we're gonna use node.js code
right I have a sample code this can be
used as template in here replace the
source bucket with the name of the
source bucket and the destination bucket
with the name of the destination bucket
this is a node.js cord that gets run
when an even to get trigger it's now
what's an even anytime there is a new
object placed in the s3 bucket it
creates an event and the even triggers
lambda and lambda checks this Sora's s3
bucket fixed the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here and click on save
alright now before you click on save
this ensure that you have the
appropriate roles defined that's all you
got to do click on save all right now I
already have created a lambda function
all right which is the same thing same
code and the role is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test guru s3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and in theory those data
should be present in the destination
bucket as well there you go
it's all done by lambda all right so
what would we learn so far we started a
discussion with the benefits of lambda
like we don't have to worry about the
server when we use lambda we don't have
to worry about scaling for lambda it
automatically scales up and scales down
we don't have to worry about the cost as
well because we're only paying for these
seconds the code is running and and when
the code is not running we're not paying
anything to it and then we spoke about
what is a W is lambda what it contains
off and what it can do and then we
discussed about the use cases of lambda
and then we had a brief discussion about
how lambda really works and how it
scales up and scales down based on the
number of requests that it receives and
finally with it a quick lab about how
lambda can be used for automatic backups
I believe you really would have enjoyed
the session about lambda we'll meet
again in another AWS video learning
tutorial like this thank you hi there if
you liked this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos turner up
and get certified click here